launching a new IP and launching a new franchise
would something like that interest you to wield
the power of something like an MCU or something
like your Miller world would you go back if you
had that much power to to mash them together you
know we're sort of trying to do it with M at the
moment because we have we've got Kingsman we
have kickass we have Ary we have two other
things we're making at the moment as well but
there has to be a reason to do it and it has
to be that everything is better with them not
just the gimmick I came up with the of days of
future past but I wanted to do it third I said
it's too early to bring it together it's too big
an event we got to do a second one where we'll
bring there's cast a young Wolverine let's have
some fun here build out this new X-Men universe
and then number three we bring them all together
and dingdong the studio was just saw dollar signs
when I gave them the idea and then went phase two
going straight to phase three shortterm great
longterm not so great it's tempting to put all
the ingredients into a pot but they still
got to have a right balance otherwise you
know I'm not really that interested in having a
I don't know a cheesecake flavored with steak in
[Music]
[Applause] it this is that's a great question I
am Coy jandro we are here at the real rejects I am
sitting down with the man who's given us Stardust
layer K kickass Kingsman and now Argy how you
doing Mr Von I'm very well how are you doing well
I I loved this film and I'm really excited to sit
down and talk to it I'm also a giant comic book
fan so I love how much you love that medium and
real quick for those listening who don't know
the plot of it I'm just going to read your IMDb
logline to avoid spoilers because there are many
Argyle is about a reclusive author named Ellie who
writes Espionage novels about a secret agent and
a global spy Syndicate who realizes the plot of
the new book she's writing starts to mirror real
world events all in real time to me this really
feels like a graphic novel come to life and you've
done my personal favorite X-Men film as well as
as I mentioned Kingsman and kickass in this new
Zenith of comic book films do you find it's more
comfortable to do stuff outside of the big two
or more things that are original Ip or adapted
from book IP that feel like a graphic novel less
scrutiny there I just want to try and do things
that are you know are original and you know when
I was a kid Back to the Future Star Wars Raiders
the these are all new new pieces of you know
they became but they weren't when they started
um or weren't wellknown IP I suppose they were IP
everything's IP um but I it's more of a challenge
but it's more rewarding now that being said there
are a few comic book characters that if somebody
rang up said do you want to have a go with this
you know it' be a long hard debate of the child
and in inner child going yes please I would love
to make a Superman movie um but at the same time
when you do these big franchises the I'm not
not worried about the fans and and you know
and and and playing with with the responsibility
of these big characters that are loved but I am
worried about the studio interference that start
making you do things that I know the fans aren't
going to like um yet you still have to do it so
it is a balancing act between between the two but
there are you know a few characters that I think
long that could be dangled in front of me that I
would definitely um be hypnotized by but who knows
where it would end up I definitely want to talk
about Comics more later on but I love what you
mentioned about the studio and I love particularly
with this film Universal agreed to only show the
first 28 minutes in the trailers and that is an
astronomical gift for this film it allowed the
shocks the surprises and all those things but I
love threeyear descriptors for the film as I was
researching you're you described it as a array of
sunshine to escape the world a blockbuster of the
heart and a wink and the perfect date movie and
it's somehow all of these and I'm wondering with
tones that are so disperate on paper what was it
like directing actors in a film that has so many
evolutions of tones to keep them on track through
the narrative especially with like Bryce's role
or cranston's it's called editing so on the you
know on the day we just do different takes we DT
it up we DT it down and then in the edit I made
sure I got choices with with you know for the
tonal balance because there's a lot of really
fun stuff that we cut out and there's some really
serious stuff that we cut out and it was all just
trying to keep the balance when I say where it's
fun and I do say this and I mean it but not silly
now some people are going to argue with that point
very quickly but I I do say I think it's Feelgood
fun with a heart and it's interesting watching how
people react or Zone in on other things like a lot
of people say oh my God the action incredible and
I go what about the romance ah [__] that [__]
other people are like oh the romance is great I
what do you think of the action like yeah it's
okay but oh my God I love the romance so it's it's
it is interesting how how when you have all these
these um ingredients some people like salt some
people like sweet you've talked a lot about how
uh the crowdsourced audience are sometimes more
helpful than the studio notes and the studios
are really good at telling you what's wrong but a
lot of times the audience is good at telling you
what's right when you're editing like you just
described it's so many different levels how do
you know which ones to read do you just open up
to a bigger crowd or how do you try to play we do
test screenings with you know four 500 people in
the room and and it's interesting a test screening
half of it you don't even need to read the note
you just sit there you feel it you know um and
on this movie the hardest thing to get right was
Clarity you know it was a complicated plot and
Landing twists and turns and we did a shorter cut
where because you know and then people watch the
movie and they were like ah I can't cope with this
it's too Bang Bang the Twist and the turn so then
I went against what I'm used to okay we're gonna
have to put stuff back in I've never done that
in my life um and then the movie gets slightly
longer but we realized a slightly longer movie
with Clarity feels shorter than a than a shorter
movie with confusion feels much longer it's so
the pacing thing was a real real lesson to me
on this one and and and yeah some people still
book reading watch the movie saying oh my God it's
too fastpaced for me and I'm like really gosh um
but and some people saying oh it's a little bit
long but I'm like trust me a little bit quicker
you you that it won it's not as satisfying
sometimes you know you have a three course
meal you got to enjoy each course maybe have even
a little bit of you know what is it called a you
know a pallet cleanser with a sbet between each
course and then it's a perfect meal or you can
eat three cheeseburgers quickly and real sick so
it does feel like a lot of different acts in one
film and I really like that it didn't have its
traditional structure and I think that's the
benefit of how you edited it and we have plenty
of three cheeseburger meals in theaters uh but
I also feel like The Meta Narrative of this this
film really suits your sensibilities you've had a
lot of meta narratives throughout your career so
far but I'm wondering with that do you visualize
like Ellie in pre-production when you're producing
a film or when you're writing a film do you have
that element we we you know the way I work is
you get the script as good as possible then
I shot list the script not storyboard I just
go through every scene knowing I need this I
need that and then I go to storyboard artists for
because sometimes I find it weird you go to some
movies and they storyboard the drama and I'm like
really this and that I mean do you really have
to storyboard that but so we we only storyboard
and stunt this the complicated stuff that no one
can get their head round so when I'm saying we're
going to do dancing and with smoke or oil skating
all that stuff you gotta you know everyone's like
what are you talking about and and then we had to
and and again the the idea of doing double action
no one could I was like no it's going to be cool
they're going to Blink we're going to have exactly
the same fight choreography but done in a certain
interpretation of Scrappy versus a superstar so
that's the stuff that you have to you know really
make crystal clear for people to follow but the
casting as well and all these characters is in
my head you know I'm like script first start you
know short listing and storyboarding while casting
and once you got the right cast and the right
storyboard and the right script and the stunt
visors then we go make the movie I we do all that
with a much smaller crew because you don't need
that many people to do that but there crew come
aboard the thousands of other people they have a
very very clear road map to follow and then the
directing wise uh you know the getting through
that pre-production very specifically directing
this there's a lot of elements without giving too
much away that are that are uh the director
has to navigate having their actor look to
camera directly like down the lens after years
of actors not being able to do that how do you
navigate that almost fourth wall break that's so
direct without a series of bloopers or having to
tweak the edit again a lot of magic happens in
the edit and there's a lot of trust I have to
trust my actors and they have to trust me and and
I always say look we can we just let's just try
it if it doesn't work we'll cut it out but if we
don't try it we can't put it in Fair yeah and the
actors you have here are all so well versed in so
many different mediums and genres it really plays
getting to see them do stuff against type and for
type depending on the tropes you're playing with
uh and and speaking of tropes playing with the
Spy drama is so important to you and I know how
much you love Bond and I know how much you love
working with guy Richie on on spy films but here
there's so much research into spy operations and
certain spy lore is that something you did extra
or new research for for Ellie or is that all stuff
you had in your back pocket I had it in my back
pocket but I had to dust it off and just remind
myself of facts and and but I I I obviously love
the world of Espionage so it's instinctive to me
and if you're playing in a field that I've been
interested in since I was seven years old um it's
just fun I'm you I'm playing like I was saying if
you ask me to to make War and Peace you know I'd
have to go read the bloody thing and it looks long
and it'll probably take me a long time and I'll
probably forget I prob you know I don't think
Warren peace and I would be a good combination I
haven't even read it so I don't know but imagine
that that because you know but meaning if you do
what you love they you know to quote Sam rock well
if you do what you love you never do a day's work
in in in your life and perfect tangent for me for
Sam Rockwell man I he's one of my favorite actors
alive he is so interestingly Char charismatic like
the way he operates in a frame and the dancing
here is maybe my favorite Sam Rockwell dancing
which is the highest praise I can give a film what
came first the action set pieces or the casting of
Sam Rockwell did you develop which developed first
uh the the action set pieces were already written
in my mind and then I thought well who could do
the dancing Sam Rockwell um comes to mind and you
know very quickly and Sam Sam's very brave and
sort of you know he's he's like a he's a bolt of
energy when he comes on with ideas and enthusiasm
so the two of us could be a pretty D if we did an
R-rated movie together we'd probably end up doing
n becoming nc7 just by default because it we would
definitely it was quite interesting I had you
know it was like um being an animal house I I
had Jason FS a little angel on my shoulder here
and I had Sam Rockwell as the devil and every day
the two of them were saying certain things to me
and I was like wait which which route am I going
to go how do I land in this cut for Universal if
I've got this man here yeah is he easier to direct
action with because he's so used to his body and
so comfortable in it he was surprising um how fit
and he's a very good boxer and he you know and he
trained so hard to play Bob fosy he was a pleasant
surprise how good he was actually you've talked
about how he can walk in a room and be a lot more
Incognito than a Henry caval or a Brad Pit and how
that worked for this kind of spy story especially
some of the action you talked about at the top the
innercut action scenes when you cast both of them
was it their Mutual like unflappable confidence
that you thought would mirror each other well or
what did you see with them as a pair for chemistry
they again it was it was like the perfect sweet
and sour um that you know you know we have Bryce
in the middle as the best filet of chicken or ve
whatever it's going to be and I needed sweet and
sour sauce to make it delicious and that's they
are I love how in every scenario Sam rockwells the
devil sour some element of chaos the hair in this
film uh has been talked about since we saw our
first poster since we saw the first trailer and
and to be vague without giving anything as we get
into the film but was the distinctive Hair Choice
an element that would allow us to have some of
the twists be uh elaborated on later on was that
an early pre-production decision to have some of
those flat top Cuts yeah no I wanted to try and
create an icon when there wasn't an icon and so
I had to give him a strong look so you'd go hey
what's that and the fact fact we could do a poster
of an unknown spy a picture from behind with just
a flat top and everyone's going hey what's that
what's the flat top so it got he became a mini
icon overnight and I didn't have any enough well
much screen time to get our girl feeling like a
a spy that's been around in the in our universe
for a long time and and is a famous spy you know
it's so that's why I thought we'll give him said
let's just give him flat top and a Nero jacket and
that's all he wears so in the movie you see him
he's always flat top and near a jacket now in the
real world if that was your look as a spy pretty
dumb you know you're going to you walk in the
room everyone's going to notice the guy with the
flat top and whether he's you know in the movie he
wears Nero pinstriped velvet you know he's always
that's his that's his Vibe like you know Kingsman
is double breasted suits and glasses and an
umbrella Aral is black top nearo color I've heard
you talk about wardrobe being so important to
characters and I love this perspective on iconic
imagery and how important that is and obviously
Comics Wolverine's mutton chops are as important
as anything but when you got a wardrobe that's
that iconic and that important how do you develop
it to have it be so immediately registerable
to all audiences do you have a certain costume
designer you like working with do you like looking
at source material like how do you develop that it
depends I've sort of got I've been doing this
for a long time so when I see characters I'm
always trying to just you know create icons so you
know I have all the things that influence me so so
male characters I'm pretty comfortable and I I
come to you know and meet the costume designer
and say this is the look I want and then they go
off and develop it uh and then on the female side
I'm not as strong um and that's where I have my
lovely wife who she goes off and and helps me um
because I'm not as good as dresses as I am with
suits Fair uh and the iconic haircut again being
something that we saw so early on there's another
very iconic haircut in this film and I'm going to
be as vague as possible but it is specifically on
a man uh that is known for other haircuts and it
is very much so a 90s Superman haircut to me um
was that something that you drew from that iconic
era of Superman or was that are we talking about
mullet man we are yes yes yeah so I just think we
got flat top man and then we have mullet man and
and all I know look look at this in screenshot of
like I don't know 20 seconds or something we've
suddenly got two icons that you can discuss and
that's what I'm talking that's my job to try and
create you know kickass you can a green wet I
think it's green I'm color blind but I think it
was a green wet it yeah yeah um it branding and
and it's very important to me and I think in this
world the stronger The Branding the more chance
you're going to get noticed seeing mullet man
on that man made me very happy as a comic fan
I I'm glad it was uh it it felt right after all
these years well there you go thank you so going
back a bit speaking of caval in the the era of
Stardust he is a total unknown to to most American
audiences as is Charlie Cox and I know you're a
big comic book fan how was it for you from the
outside to see one of your guys become the Man of
Steel and another one become The Man Without Fear
it's sort of weirdly satisfying in an odd way
it's just not it's it's it's it's uh every time
I've worked with someone or Tom Hardy becoming
Venom uh Daniel Craig becoming Bond um I'm sure
there's other you know Taylor Johnson's Craven
now uh you know yeah Aaron is Craven yeah I me I'm
sure there's other I mean that's what so odd I'm
trying to go through the actors I've worked with
to seeing them how they come these sort of icons
that I've Loved or superheroes or spies so it's
weird it's also a bit of a bugger because then
when I watch the movies it's not quite as magical
for me because I know deep down that Daniel Craig
isn't really James Bond or um Charlie cany um so
um so that's a little bit odd you know the magic
is harder and but they're all brilliant at what
they do and and it's um it's a lovely it's and
it's really nice when you work with actors who
are starting their career and they're nervous and
then you see them becoming these Mega stars and
having such success um you just well done them
and and Pedro his his last few years after Pedro
yeah that was like that by the way when when we
cast Pedro in um in the kingsman's gold golden
was called kingsman the golden service that's how
tied I am the go what is it golden circle circle
um and when I um you know when I gave Pedro
the part he was so like no I really got the
part he was so humble about it and this guy had
been working so hard for so long and I couldn't
understand it when I I said I said this guy is a
movie star this guy's a fantastic actor he looks
great and and I remember saying when you do this
movie you I I knew he he would just be a rocket
for him and um and it's great he's a sweet sweet
man and it shows in the work to see how much each
of these actors has to do in these performances
because you are making them icons you are making
them their own IP as we discussed at the top and
I I remember hearing about like Daniel kuuya and
and tan and these finalists for Kingsmen and how
everyone kind of launched from that point was
there ever a moment when you were making Kingsmen
that you took a step back or even layer cake going
back further where you thought like oh this is the
next wave of movie star this is the next set of
these people and even beyond the superhero IP is
there a sense of like family where you guys keep
in touch with these big announcements I remember
Daniel on on the lir cake just looking through the
camera there's an odd thing with movie stars or
even musical with j j leap as an example and um
even just with Boy George we worked with him on
on electric energy on this and you look through
the cam camera and a star I don't know how to
exp the lens sort of melts around them or they
melt into the lens I don't know what it is but it
is so obvious right I mean I'm not some Maestro
that sees things that nobody else can we all see
it you know that's why they become a star we're
all looking at them in the same way and it's not
necessarily they being goodlooking right as well
that's a real you know like Jean Wilder uh for
example the camera melted on him it's there is
a Charis there's a something and I there I say
there is an X Factor there is something a person
has that the camera or the microphone or the stage
wherever they go on whether they're a chef whether
they're an artist just something that unknown
happens and it's magical and it's an Alchemy
like no other um and so when I cast these people
I'm just seeing it for what it is it's not me it's
just I'm just capturing what they are oozing um
and some of them you know and so I'm not really
that surprised I'm I'm sort of I'm just proud of
them and having being a tiny part of their journey
I I do want to talk about casting a bit later on
because there is so much in the world of casting
right now as we're seeing I just love that comic
book films are beyond the medium now and they're
becoming their own thing and and making something
like Argyle launching a new IP and launching a new
franchise but uh the world of kickass has its own
spin in IP because did you read uh Mark Miller's
new big game event that just happened big game
event yeah so he just concluded um basically
all of his worlds he just put them all together so
Nemesis kickass Kingsman all came back together in
an Avengers esque event and he called it big game
so basically he made his phase one and brought
your guys from Kingsman to your guys from kickass
and and mesh them together in a fascinating way
and I was wondering if you could get back into
that world did that would something like that
interest you to wield the power of something like
an MCU or something like your Miller world would
you go back if you had that much power to to
mash them together um yeah Never Say Never I
mean I I you know we're sort of trying to do it
with MV at the moment because we have we've got
Kingsman we have kickass we have Ary we have two
other things we're making at the moment as well
and so we we're getting these characters but
there has to be a reason to do it and it has
to be that everything is better with them not
just the gimmick and then it's you you you do
great I I had this argument on um Days of Future
Past because I you know did first class and then
I came up with the idea of Days of Future Past and
then but I wanted to do it third I said it's too
early to bring it together it's too big an event
we got to do a second one where we'll bring let's
cast a young Wolverine let's have some fun here
build up the build out this new X-Men universe
and then number three we bring them all together
and ding dong the studio was just saw dollar signs
when I gave them the idea and then went [__]
number phase two we're going straight to phase
three which I thought was you know shortterm great
longterm not so great um it's tempting to put all
the ingredients into a pot but they still got to
have a right balance otherwise you know I'm not
really that interested in having a I don't know a
cheesecake flavored with steak in it yeah back to
the three cheeseburgers there really should be an
Atif in between I I love that you brought up Days
of Future Past because I really do think it's
something that had the good source and then it
kind of like kitty Pride had power she didn't
have and there were choices made that that did
feel like it was serving itself instead of serving
The Narrative is there any X-Men story you would
love to see adapted now that we're bringing
the mutants into the MCU as a comic fan just
from the outside is there a story line you'd love
to see on screen I'm going to say something b a
little bit controversial but one of my favorite
storylines which I was involved with was X3 and
the Cure and I didn't think and that I found
fascinating so if I was asked you I I'd love to
have done do that properly because I did think the
idea of to be cured of something amazing was and
now with what happened with you know the vaccine
and covid and and mass vaccinations comp and I
thought that plotline um was it Bendis no who did
that uh think it was Weeden on astonishing we it
was Weeden yeah the first astonishing X-Men Arc I
believe it was that c Arc yeah I think it was Josh
yeah Weeden said that that would be something I'd
like to I think with the modern world could be a
very powerful story line it's impossibly topical
and I and I do think it it lends itself to the
commentaries on like Prejudice and and obviously
the inherent bigotry in the X-Men when you were
developing X-Men um and you had all the the studio
rumbly jumbly was there ever anyone you put forth
as a casting idea since casting is so important to
you we didn't get to see or is there anyone that
you'd love to see as an X-Men rumbly jumbly I will
quote you for that that'll be my new that's my new
word of the day um let me just think about that um
no I sort of got everybody I wanted I mean it all
it it all fell into place um I had to fight very
hard to cast Jennifer Lawrence ironically and I
did have a problem casting fast Bender because the
poor guy the mustache and the auditions because he
was playing I think Kung um and the studio kept
saying well we don't like his mustache and I was
like you know there's a thing go a ra and movie we
will get rid of it and they're like yeah but that
mustach I like stop talking about the mustache
this guy is brilliant um so so as I said I fought
for who I wanted so you know I I I I think the
casting was pretty damn good in that film yeah I
mean Lucas Till Zoe kravit seeing a lot of people
again that have now become household names from
that cast at and to me first class feels the
most like an X-Men movie not a mutant movie
like the the heart of what the X-Men is is there
uh as they bring the X-Men into the MCU and and
you following as a fan of the comic books is there
anything you'd love to see the MCU transition into
using the element of the fox characters like
the Fantastic 4 or the MCU would you like to
see them interacting or would you like to see it a
little off sides I would like to see I I think why
the MCU worked so well they were disciplined at
the beginning keep the cat keep these characters
separate get you know get have one or two movies
and then you that's why I didn't think Justice
League worked because they just slapped all
these characters together but we hadn't spent
enough time with them to really enjoy them coming
together and that's why the Avengers were so great
because we'd had enough individual movies and
then and you it was so you know Kevin feige was
a master how he did that so if I was doing it I'd
say fan for X-Men make them right so set it up do
one or two movies of both and then slowly start
letting the tentacles go that's what I would do I
I totally agree and it always feels like the X-Men
are just outside of New York for a reason like
Upstate Westchester intentionally is over there
is there anything that would lure you back to MCU
anything with like Kevin figer anyone running it
over there that would call to you enough I know
I don't want to give anything away but like just
as a fan of the comics a character you'd like to
play with um yeah if they called me up and said I
mean look I love that universe so um and I Kevin
so yeah I would never say never they he called me
up and said look we want to like I don't know Iron
Man you know originally I wanted to do Iron Man
about 22 years ago when it was at new line and I
found the script and I was like this is the future
I want to make Iron Man and everyone said you're
just crazy No One's Gonna it's the dumbest title
and what a guy a rich guy builds a superhero Iron
costume never going to work so um you know so so
if I read you know never say never well before we
get out of here the DC Universe is also jumping
again it's starting in its own way and I know how
much respect you have for gun and saffron uh those
announcements for Comic fans were insane some of
the stuff they said I'm shocked they're making
even in this age of superhero was there a certain
announcement that you are most excited to see if
not work on well Millie Alcock a Supergirl was
I met with her again eight months ago I saw saw
her in in House of dragon went this is a future
star so we met there's a project I I I thought
should be grateful and she turned me down which
I was like okay that's she's um that's okay fair
enough um um and I'm not surprised she's now going
to become become Supergirl she's brilliant she's
absolutely brilliant is there anyone you've met
with in in all your years that you could see
off the top of your head as someone with the
DCU or MCU with the history of your casting these
people that feel like movie stars through the lens
is there anyone that hasn't yet hit that Tipping
Point Taran Edon yeah I and I know everybody says
him is Wolverine but I I personally he's he
doesn't look like he smells bad enough oh he
does perfect that was my only issue I want a
wolverine that looks like the peanuts on the
bar are the smell that he has um so before we get
out of here I also know your love of James Bond
is profound and both you and Henry caval have
been almost bond in your own ways with Henry's
insane streak of almost Cullen almost Bond and now
the Superman chaos was there a moment when making
this it felt like there was a bit of of karma for
you get it to make your your spy Thriller through
Argy with someone we've all wanted as bond for so
long yeah I wouldn't say it's karma I just say it
was a the right it was the Stars you know aligning
correctly um and it was fun and um I still think
if Henry if they chose Henry to be Bond they
they they it will do very very well I think
Henry will make it his own vehicle but he's so in
Fleming wrote Henry caval as you know or Henry C
you know I don't know whether Henry caval read
Bond when he was a kid and just molded himself
on that because he he as close to a real life
Bond as anyone I've ever met and it absolutely
plays and I hope I mean have 10 years down the
line the H you Kingdom Come and maybe you can
bring him back over there too because I'd love
to see it there's a lot of that element here is
there anything you'd love to do with Henry next or
any of this cast because I love your work with Sam
and Bryce here is incredible I would love to work
with them again we have ideas we've discussed it
but we need people to see this movie first of
all if if arar works then there's going to be
a lot more surprises and fun to come I love that
this is book four and I love that you want to do
book one next I love that Ellie is a real author
there's so many elements of this that I can't
wait to understand How Deep The Meta Rabbit
Hole goes but most of all I really appreciate
all your work man and your work with guy Richie
producing snatch got me interested in how films
are made so I really appreciate everything you've
done and your love Comics is also so wonderful
to see so thank you so much man well thank you
for your time I appreciate it have a great one